europe shows no signs of abating
the depravity of the war was once again
on full display yesterday following the
missile strike in kremenchuk in central
poltova region
hundreds of people perhaps even some
trying to get a respite from the daily
horrors of war suffered one of the most
shocking attacks of the conflict when a
shopping center was hit by what are
reported to be russian missiles
18 civilians were reportedly killed and
59 injured
the final toll may be much higher
this incident which should be
investigated was the latest in a new
wave of airstrikes and missile attacks
in kiev journey heath odessa mikolayaf
harkief and other cities far from the
front lines with many civilians killed
or injured
presently the most intense fighting is
in and around the towns of sever donetsk
the sinchonsk slavyansk and slavyansk in
the donbas
heavy fighting is also reported around
the cities of harkief and hair sun
in scenes reminiscent of world wars
large-scale artillery duels are
devastating industrial areas with
thousands of civilians forced to hide in
basements or flee
for their lives
large military casualties are claimed on
both sides
mr president civilians continue to pay
too high a price in this war
as of 26 june
the office of the high commissioner for
human rights recorded ten thousand six
hundred and thirty one civilian
casualties in the country
four thousand seven hundred thirty one
killed
and five thousand nine hundred injured
these are figures based on verified
incidents the actual figures are
considerably higher
most of the civilian casualties recorded
were caused by explosive weapons with a
wide
impact area
many of these weapons are inherently
indiscriminate when used in populated
areas and therefore result in increased
civilian casualties and devastating
humanitarian impacts
the commission of inquiry on ukraine
concluded earlier this month its first
mission to the country including visits
to bucha erpin
and
sumi though only in the initial stages
of its work
the commission received information in
visited cities that quote
may support claims that serious
violations of international human rights
law and international humanitarian law
perhaps reaching war crimes and crimes
against humanity have been committed end
quote
the work of the commission of inquiry
the prosecutor of the international
criminal court and other fact-finding
efforts are essential for establishing
accountability for the crimes and
atrocities committed during this war
this work must lead to justice
it is imperative for the people of
ukraine it is also crucial if we hope to
be able to prevent such violations in
the future
wherever they threaten to occur
mr president since 24 february over 8.8
million people across ukraine have
received some form of humanitarian
assistance and protection services
at least 16 million people need such aid
needs are increasing especially ahead of
winter
humanitarian partners are working on a
winterization assistance plan
and revising the flash appeal which runs
through august to cover the needs
through the end of 2022
women in particular
are facing immense hardship when it
comes to health safety and access to
food
a rapid gender analysis by you and women
and care in april
revealed that women are increasingly
becoming heads of household and leaders
in their communities as men are
conscripted
they must be included in formal
decision-making processes related to
humanitarian efforts peacemaking and
other areas that directly impact their
lives
perilous conditions are hampering
efforts by humanitarian partners to
reach civilians
or for them to access the support they
need
one statistic sheds light on this
concern
since 24 february the world health
organization
has recorded 323 attacks on health care
facilities and personnel resulting in 76
deaths
we strongly remind all parties of their
obligations under international
humanitarian law
all adequate measures must be taken to
protect civilians and civilian
infrastructure
mr president ukraine is suffering the
largest human displacement crisis in the
world today
since the start of the russian invasion
more than one quarter of the country's
population 12 million people have been
forced from their
homes within ukraine over 7.1 million
people remain displaced by the war
unhcr estimates there are over 5.2
million refugees present across europe
over 3.5 million refugees from ukraine
have registered for temporary protection
or similar national protection schemes
in europe
the un remains committed to provide
support for the government-led responses
in host countries
also given the increasing protracted
nature of the conflict we must not
neglect ukraine's long-term recovery and
rebuilding needs
using early socioeconomic assessments
undp launched a new resilience and
recovery program to support the
ukrainian government's emergency
response its commitment to public
services and to keeping the economy
running as well as to help assess
priority needs to deliver for the people
of ukraine
mr president the war is having
devastating consequences not only on the
country and the immediate region but far
beyond ukraine's borders
as the secretary general noted on 8 9
during the launch of the second brief of
the u.n global crisis response group on
food energy and finance
the war is exacerbating the greatest
cost of living crisis in a
generation price shocks in the global
food energy and fertilizer fertilizer
markets are escalating
in a world already grappling with the
cobit 19 pandemic and climate change
to address this multi-dimensional threat
strong political will
across the multilateral community and a
comprehensive approach is foremost
necessary
mr president we've run out of words to
describe the senselessness futility and
cruelty of this war
as the secretary-general warned
for those on the ground every day bling
brings new bloodshed and suffering
and for people around the world the war
together with other crises is
threatening to unleash an unprecedented
wave of hunger and destitution
leaving social and economic chaos in its
wake
no country or community will be left
untouched
the cycle of death destruction
dislocation and disruption must stop
for the sake of ukraine russia and the
entire world thank you mr president
i thank miss dicarlo for her briefing
i now give the floor to his excellency
mr hulo dimir zelensky president of
ukraine
[Music]
thank you very much
[Music]
dear ladies and gentlemen first of all
let me
thank
the albanian presidency in the eu and
security council for promptly convening
this meeting at ukraine's request and
for the opportunity to address you
unfortunately as of now the united
nations
does not have a legal definition
of the term
terrorist states agreed by all u.n
members but this war that russia is
waging against ukraine demonstrates not
only the meaning of this concept but
also the urgent necessity to enshrine it
legally at the level of the united
nations and punish
any terrorist state
take a look at just recent events
of a few recent days in ukraine a few
from the 125 days of russia's full-scale
war of conquest against ukraine
saturday 25th of june 60 two russian
missiles hit our cities
sunday 26th of june and more 10 more
rockets
one of them hit a residential building
in the capital city of cave
three stories of a simple building were
demolished another rocket is exploded in
the yard of an ordinary kindergarten
monday 27th of june a missile strike in
kremenchuk
those who carried out this strike could
not have been unaware of directing a
missile on a simple trade center one of
many shopping malls to be found
everywhere in the world
as of now no 18 people are reported to
have been killed
but unfortunately there may be more
uh another 50 people are wounded and
dozens
are missing
seven fragments of bodies have been
found ripped off limbs
hands
and feet
of the people
and if the russian state claims that all
the despectives
suffered not from its missile strike
then i suggest the united nations sent
either a special representative of the
secretary general of the united nations
or planning potentially commissioned to
the site of the terrorist act of
tremendous so that the u.n could
independently find out all the
information
and see that this indeed was a russian
missile strike
russian army also
used rocket artillery against a queue of
people lined up for water that took
place in the city of nissanchangs
lugansk region ordinary peaceful people
none of them served in the military just
a queue of people for water eight people
were killed including a 15 year old boy
named danilo the eldest of the victims
was 68 years old and i want you
to hear the the names of four women
killed in the strike victoria irina
orlana and ludmila
almost on a daily basis cruel russian
strikes are targeted against
just yesterday nine were killed 29
wounded five of whom are children
i want you to know their names
10 years old clip 12 years old that was
a russian artillery strike against
ordinary residential buildings
today at five o'clock in the morning the
russian army uh struck mikko life and
the town of ochakev in the mikko live
region
in a charity of three people were killed
a girl six years old his name was eve
a man named magamet who was 76
a woman by the name of galena who was 50
among the wounded is a child a boy
three months of age
he was born after
russian full-scale uh invasion started
his name is wala dima
and he's severely injured he is in
intensive care
i stress once again a child a
three-month-old child
two more missiles today
hit the city of sloanoise slovyansk in
donbass
the
long-suffering donbass fermented donbass
that russia has humiliated since 2014
just a few hours before this address of
mine to you to the u.n security council
to missiles it odessa region
the
city of nepal was also targeted and one
of the missiles destroyed
a car service station not a military
station but a visual
car service and i have a question to you
ladies and gentlemen who of you does not
agree that this is terrorism
if in any other part of the world
any organization
acted just like russia who is killing
ukrainians if a country killed any
peaceful people that would definitely be
recognized as terrorism such an
organization would become an enemy for
all of humankind therefore what is
punished at the level of concrete
criminals and criminal organizations
must not go unchecked at the level of
the state which has become a terrorist
daily terrorist act
without weekends
every day
they are working as terrorists
the u.n charter confers on the u.n
security council the primary
responsibility for the maintenance of
international peace and security article
6 of chapter 2 of the u.n charter
clearly states that a member of the un
which has persistently violated the
principles contained at the present
charter may be expelled from the
organization by the general assembly
of the security council although russia
is violating fundamental principles of
the un and the international legal order
it is still not held to account
at the global level
it still remains in your agencies and
even enjoys the privileges of the seat
it occupies
the seat of the permanent member of the
u.s security council which russia
occupies solely
due to the short-sightedness of
politicians
at the end of the cold war
russia does not have the right to take
part in discussing a voting in regard to
the war in ukraine which is unprovoked
and simply colonialist of the part of
russia i urge you to deprive the
delegation of the terrorist state of its
powers in the u.n
um
general assembly that is possible that
is necessary that is fair
russia does not have the right to
remain in the unsc and that path is not
too arduous as some may believe
if we exercise some consistent
consistency and appropriate political
will that is the only logical way
for the u.n childhood to work and be
respected by all members of the
organization furthermore our
organization now has sufficient strength
to pull to account the terrorist state
chapter 7 of the u.n charter allows
establishing a special
international tribunal for investigating
the actions of russian occupiers on
ukrainian soil the word genocide has
repeatedly been used and all of you have
seen what russian occupiers have done in
our city of butcher
each of you can obtain information on
how many mass graves appeared around
single city of marijuana
after the russian army raised it to the
crowd
it was a city of 500 000
residents and now it lies in ruins in
the case of genocide in rwanda the u.n
security council established an
international tribunal during six months
since the beginning of the genocide
since the beginning of the russian
full-scale invasion of ukraine
more than four months have passed since
the beginning of russia's war against
ukraine in donbass and the occupation of
ukrainian peninsula of crimea
which has been repeatedly condemned at
the level of the u.n general assembly
more than eight years have passed we
need to act urgently to do everything to
make russia stop the killing spree
the killings of children people everyone
we need to hold into account for the
terrorism
otherwise
it will
terror terrorist activity in other
countries of europe and asia
baltic states poland moldova kazakhstan
many nations
have already heard threats from russian
officials and state propagandists
i'm grateful to all the diligent and
civilized states who share
our position and help defend
the international legal order this
meeting of the
uh u.n security council convened is
convened after the russian missile
strike increment
but in fact the meeting of the u.n
security council
may not be a jaunt at all
it can go on around the clock day after
day for us to have time to discuss every
terrorist act of the russian state
the u.n charter
gives all the levers to influence any
violator of the rules of the
organization
any aggressor
any terrorist state
and i urge you
to take advantage of these leaders
it is imperative
to deprive the russian delegation of the
opportunity to manipulate the u.n it is
imperative
to make it impossible for russia to stay
in the u.n security council until its
terrorism continues it is imperative to
establish a tribunal for investigating
everything that the russian military
have done against ukrainians and it is
imperative
to
give the legal definition of the notion
state terrorism at the u.n level all
russian action must receive legal
assessment
and global sanctions
for the fact that russia is destructing
international legal order thank you for
your attention i wish to say just one
more thing various countries worldwide
can have uh different uh attitudes to
where's
uh worldwide but they
similarly commemorate the victims not
only the military but
every person every child
who is
dying unfortunately due to this tragedy
the tragedy of war
that is the usual thing
usually treat with respect and sympathy
those
who have been unfairly killed
and only the killers do not commemorate
those whom they have killed and i ask
you now i will be very much grateful
if you could commemorate
all the ukrainians who have been killed
in this war all the adults or all of our
children
tens of thousands of people and i ask
you to commemorate them with a mo with a
minute of silence
thank you very much indeed
it is a great honor for us
thank you for support
thank you very much indeed
i thank his excellency mr zelinski for
his statement
i shall now make a statement in my
capacity as a representative of albania
thank you usg dicarlo for this update
again a troubling one on this issue
colleagues
a senseless war of aggression that could
and must have been avoided has entered
its fifth month
125 days of outspread destruction
mounting civilian casualties and
continued pain inflicted on millions of
people across ukraine
other millions across the world
find themselves victims as collateral
damage of a war that has nothing to do
with them that is weaponizing everything
energy trade communication including
primarily food
colleagues let's remind ourselves on
29th march
five weeks after the start of its war of
choice in ukraine russia announced its
withdrawal of forces from the kiev area
the reason provided then was that it was
a goodwill gesture to favor negotiations
between the parties
the truth proved very different
the attempt to take in kiev failed
spectacularly
negotiations went nowhere
war
intensified instead
russia continues its massive assault on
ukraine threatening europe
running against every human effort
invested since world war ii to build
global peace through the international
rule of law
as war has shifted ferociously to the
east
life returned to some sort of normalcy
in kiev until missiles starting again
falling from the sky with an unmistaken
message
russia can hit you at will
anywhere
anytime just because it can
last sunday nearly 1 000 people found
themselves under a russian airstrike
which hit a shopping mall in the city of
cremencuk in central ukraine
reportedly
tens of people
lost their lives and several dozens were
injured
what possible justification can be
provided to missiles thrown over a
commercial center in the very heart of
an urban area
what can possibly explain such blatant
indiscriminate brutality against
civilians
we have heard so many times
russia has continued to deny tragedy
civilians but overwhelming evidence like
this one proves again and again the
contrary
have we forgotten that kiev was
deliberately targeted last april
as the u.n secretary general was
visiting the city
reports speak now of deliberate attacks
in protesting to the g7 meeting
if it were so
why should civilians including children
pay the price of such despicable
symbolism
indiscriminate attacks on civilian
infrastructure any and innocent
civilians constitute war crimes we all
know it
those who decide to attack shopping
centers shelters schools hospitals
kindergarten apartment buildings are
well aware of possible civilian
casualties
they know they are committing war crimes
when their responsibility is
to protect civilians
they must pay for these actions
colleagues
this aggression is not limited to
ukraine only
zealous commentators of the state
propaganda but also senior canadian
officials fill the air with worst case
scenario of deploying weapons of mass
destruction
including as we have heard more than
once nuclear cyber rattling
we notice a dramatic increase of cyber
warfare and advanced disinformation
attacks
further the current food and security
crisis continues to spread around the
world
global food prices are now at an all
time high
this is the parallel war that russia is
waging against the world
it has transformed the war in ukraine
from a local act of aggression
to an acute international challenge
we know that millions of tons of grain
are piled in ukraine
out of it eight million tons are said to
be in the occupied areas of russia and
russia is reportedly stealing it from
ukraine
meticulous and professional
investigation from the bbc shows how
this is carried out in donbass
and not only for the grain but also for
other ukrainian assets
russia has already occupied 20 percent
of the ukrainian territory but its
appetite has increased
colleagues
this war is paralyzing ukraine it is
destroying its industry its roads and
schools and its health system along the
way
it is killing civilians it is punishing
its youth and is destroying the fabric
of a society
but also it is testing the resolve of
all those who truly believe in the rules
international order in rules-based
international order
in the respect of the u.n charter
therefore this is no time to stay aside
international support for ukraine and
its people is a moral and solidarity
issue
it is to choose to stand on the right
side that of the law
of rights
of life
of dignity
one day this war will be over
but the way it will end
matters to all of us
if we want to preserve the rule of law
we must make sure that everyone knows
the cost of aggression against another
country
we welcome the recent commitments of g7
for a new package of coordinated actions
aimed at increasing pressure on russia
over its war in ukraine
we also welcome the latest decision of
the european union
colleagues let me end with this
this war must stop with full and
immediate withdrawal of the russian
forces and military equipment from the
territory from the entire territory of
ukraine
the sooner the better for all ukraine
russia and the entire world
thank you
i resume my function as president of the
council
i now give the floor to the
representative of the united states
thank you mr president
thank you under secretary general de
carlo for your compelling if ultimately
heartbreaking
briefing
i thank president zielinski for
addressing the council again today
we were honored by his presence here
but i think we're all horrified by the
circumstances under which we meet
and we express our deepest condolences
to him and the people of the ukraine
for the horrors they continue to suffer
on a daily basis
including the senseless attack by
putin's forces that destroyed the
shopping center in creminchuk
america stands as always
united with ukraine
it would already be an outrage if
yesterday's attack was a horrific
exception
but it is not even that
the attack fits into a cruel pattern one
where the russian military kills
civilians and destroys civilian
infrastructure
in ukraine
the kremlin has demonstrated time and
time again that it is trying to
subjugate ukraine its sovereignty its
people its spirit
putin keeps trying to intimidate and
divide ukraine's partners
we have shown and will continue to show
that our support for ukraine is resolute
i expect the representative from the
russian federation
in a moment to try to obfuscate
to avoid responsibility and blame others
for this tragedy
but no one here will be fooled
we all see the grim reality for what it
is
and the reality is that russia's war of
choice has led directly to the
destruction of crowded malls grocery
stores theaters hospitals and schools
and the innocent civilians inside them
make no mistake there is ample publicly
available evidence that russia and
russia alone is responsible for these
attacks
and make no mistake deliberate and
indiscriminate attacks on civilians and
civilian objects
constitute war crimes
the united states has previously
assessed
that members of russia's armed forces
have committed war crimes in ukraine
i repeat to be clear war crimes
the evidence is mounting and it cannot
be ignored
we have seen too many credible reports
of the bombing of schools and hospitals
like the maternity hospital and mario
pool
the killing of aid workers the targeting
of a civilians attempting to flee for
their lives or standing in line for
water as the president just reminded us
we've seen forced relocation of
thousands of ukrainian civilians and the
brutal execution-style murder of those
going about their daily business
kombucha
we call upon all fellow council members
including those who are failing to
condemn what is in front of them
to speak the full truth
we all have a responsibility to make
clear the moral culpability that russia
holds in this war of choice
there is no such thing as both sides
when it comes to these recent attacks
the international community must hold
those who perpetrated and ordered these
crimes to account
justice must be served justice must come
for russia's military and political
leadership as well as for its military
rank and file who commit war crimes or
other atrocities
the united states supports all
international investigations into these
crimes including those being conducted
by the icc the un and the osce
we have welcomed the international
criminal court's decision
to open an investigation into atrocity
crimes committed in ukraine
and with our eu colleagues
we are supporting the ukrainian national
authorities
specifically the office of the
prosecutor general
as these authorities investigate and
prepare to prosecute war crimes cases
at the same time
the world
has come together to say enough is
enough
just yesterday leaders of g7 countries
reaffirmed our solidarity and unwaving
commitment
to ukraine's sovereignty
our leaders made clear that we will help
ukraine defend itself and choose its own
future free from external pressure or
influence
and the united states and the world will
continue to support ukraine for as long
as it takes we will not rest
until russia ends this cruel and
senseless war
how many more attacks will there be
before those on this council who
continue to tap dance around russia's
cup ability
demonstrate that they care more about
the protection of civilians than
protecting their own interests and start
speaking of the steps russia needs to
take to resolve the crisis that it
started
colleagues russia started this war
russia is the one committing atrocities
against civilians
and only russia can end this war by
withdrawing its forces from ukraine
and reaching a political settlement with
ukraine's democratically elected
government
let us all
continue to do everything in our power
to see that day soon
thank you
i thank the representative of the united
states for their
joselu the participation of the
president
participated
in solidarity with ukraine
foreign
yes
jurisdictions
the population
and russia bears the full responsibility
is
particularly in those regions
the united nations
of brazil
thank you mr president
mr president i thank the albanian
presidency for convening this urgent
security council security council
meeting on the conflict in ukraine
and i thank under secretary rosa marie
de carlo for her briefing
brazil
received with deep concern recent news
of air strikes on or near densely
populated areas in ukrainian cities
of which
the commercial center of kremen shook
yesterday is the most dramatic example
we deeply regret
the loss of human life and the
destruction of urban and industrial
infrastructure which will be undoubtedly
have serious consequences for the
already dire humanitarian situation in
the country
attacks against civilian objects
especially in destiny populated areas
encourage a perverse logic of
retaliation we urge the parties
to allow an impartial investigation into
these incidents and to refrain from
actions that could result in increased
civilian casualties
brazil reiterates its call for parties
to respect their obligations under the
un charter and international
humanitarian law
including observing the principles of
distinction and proportionality
this comprises the protection of
civilians in all circumstances
entailing the exercise of restraint by
military forces and the establishment of
mechanisms for evacuating areas directly
impacted by operations
we encourage parties to engage in
constructive dialogue to achieve this
common goal
mr president
four months after the start of the
conflict
it should be clear that there is no
alternative to a political solution
it is unreasonable for military
operations should be prolonged with no
prospect for an end to the immense human
suffering imposed on civilian
populations
we renew our appeal for an immediate for
any immediate cessation of hostilities
and establishment of peace negotiations
without delay or preconditions
this council is responsible for creating
conditions for dialogue we should
redouble
efforts to seek solutions that favor
peace negotiations and minimize the
impacts of the conflict both in ukraine
and
and in other affected regions and i
thank you
i thank the representative of brazil for
their statement and i give the floor to
the representative of the united kingdom
thank you president
and i join others in thanking usg de
carlo for her briefing
and while we welcome president
zielenski's participation again we
deeply regret the circumstances that
brought him here today
president
just over four months since the start of
its illegal invasion
russia's war against ukraine continues
russia continues to pummel ukraine's
eastern donbass region
in an effort to seize full control
and over the weekend
russia launched an intense barrage of
cruise missile attacks at targets across
ukraine
including hitting a shopping center in
kremenchuk with over one thousand people
inside
we heard from president zielenski
the roll call of the recent dead
and extend our condolences to their
families and their friends
when the world calls for peace
for dialogue
and adherence to international law
russia answers
with escalation
with missiles
and targeting civilians
more attacks more destruction
more death
and as i'm sure we will hear again today
more war propaganda
more lies more disinformation
nor can we ignore the prominent role of
belarus in acting as a direct staging
post for the attacks over the weekend
and yesterday
we praise the extraordinary bravery and
resolve of the ukrainian people
in the face of this brutal assault
on its sovereignty and territorial
integrity
and its very existence
as a country
ukraine is entitled to defend itself
as any of us would if our cities
towns and villages were subject to
repeated relentless missile strikes
by a foreign army focused on wiping out
our existence
so we will continue
to support ukraine
to exercise this right of self-defense
and to re-secure
its privileges and rights
under the u n charter
we yet again reiterate the calls of the
international community for russia to
end its illegal invasion
withdraw
outside ukraine's internationally
recognized borders
and enter into dialogue and negotiation
at a time when we are facing the
existential threats of climate change
and food insecurity following a global
pandemic russia
must end its illegal war
and its blockade of ukraine's ports
thank you president
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom for their statement and i give
the floor to the representative of
ireland
thank you very much mr president and i
would like to thank the under secretary
general for her briefing a briefing
which highlights yet again
the brutality of this unlawful war
for four months mr president
we have called for an end to the
unjustified and unjustifiable
war being waged against ukraine
yet as each day passes reports of
violations of human rights and
international humanitarian law by russia
grow
civilians in ukraine continue to pay the
highest price
on monday
russian forces attacked a shopping mall
in kremenchuk full of civilians going
about their ordinary lives
this appears to have been a clear attack
against civilians and civilian
infrastructure in flagrant violation of
international humanitarian law
the consequences of this attack
report by credible media sources is
civilians killed
mr president we have heard today
how civilians continue to bear the brunt
of russia's unconscionable war
all allegations of violations of
international human rights and
humanitarian law must be investigated
and those responsible held to account
parties to conflict must comply with
international humanitarian law
including the obligation to distinguish
between civilians and combatants
and to attack only military object
objectives
the prohibitions against indiscriminate
and disproportionate attacks and the
obligation to take all feasible
precautions in attack
mr president
compliance is not optional
yesterday yesterday's russian strike on
kamenchuk is not the first on ukraine's
towns and cities we know
we deplore russia's use of explosive
weapons including prohibited cluster
munitions in populated areas without
regard for civilians
the un human rights monitoring mission
in ukraine has recorded over ten
thousand civilian casualties
most of which have been caused by the
use of explosive weapons
we condem indiscriminate and
disproportionate attacks in all
circumstances
we are committed to ensuring
accountability for the atrocious crimes
taking place in ukraine
and recognize the important role of the
ongoing investigation of the
international criminal court in helping
to pursue this
we must not accept impunity for those
inflicting such horrors
not in ukraine
not anywhere in the world we once again
call on the russian federation to comply
with its obligations under international
law there must be full safe and
unhindered humanitarian access for
humanitarian
personnel to reach civilians including
those who choose to remain in ukraine
and those who are unable to depart
including the elderly
they are not combatants and must be
protected in accordance with
international humanitarian law
the russian federation must allow those
seeking to leave their towns and cities
in ukraine to do so safely to
destinations of their own choosing
president
can end its aggression if it chooses
but even while it chooses to execute an
illegal war
it still has obligations under
international law and it must comply
with those obligations
we call again on the russian federation
to end its war and to withdraw all
forces unconditionally from the entirety
of the sovereign territory of ukraine
thank you
president
i thank the representative of ireland
for their statement and i give a floor
to representative of kenya
thank you mr president
i also thank anders secretary general
madame rosemary de carlo for her
briefing
as well as his excellency presidency
landscape for his address
kenya stands in solidarity with the
people of ukraine
who are suffering
the failure of the multilateral system
to bring an end to a war that continues
and abated
in disregard
of the result
of the united nations
to save succeeding generations
from the scourge of war
a war
whose catastrophic impact in ukraine and
across the world is worsening
by the day
we are gravely concerned by the latest
developments
especially in
mekolayev
jonev
zotoma
love
odessa
and chakasi regions
as well as in cave
kegev
and kramachuk cities
the reported intensified airstrikes and
missile shelling in these regions and
cities
are destroying civilian objects
with a growing toll on civilian
casualties
these indiscriminate acts
constitute a violation of the u.n
charter
international law
and international humanitarian law
kenya condemns
the disproportionate use of force
and the targeting of civilians and
objects indispensable to the survival of
civilian populations
including residential homes
health facilities
shelters
shopping malls as well as power and
water infrastructure
we are concerned that the continued
destruction of civilian infrastructure
is significantly impeding ukraine's
ability to engage in international trade
including the export of key commodities
particularly agricultural products and
farm inputs such as fertilizer
in addition
the blockade of ukraine's access to the
black sea
has disrupted the global food supply
chain
and this
is worsening food in security especially
in conflict situations and fragile
economies in the global south with the
surging inflation rates
and the spike in food and fuel prices
globally
this armed conflict is undermining
efforts to build back from the covet 19
pandemic
we commend the secretary general for his
efforts including the establishment of
the global crisis response group
on food
energy and finance
this is a good
first step towards the establishment of
instruments that conclusion the most
vulnerable from the effects of the
conflict
of critical importance mr president
is the imperative to immediately stop
further infliction of suffering
on civilians especially
the vulnerable groups including women
children and the elderly
we therefore urge the parties to adhere
to international humanitarian law
including the four 1949 geneva
conventions and its first additional
protocol of 1977
as well as ensure the protection of
civilian population and detainees
we call on them to shift their focus
to an immediate cessation of the war
refrain from any actions that may
further escalate the situation
and prioritize the use of diplomatic
tools to resolve the conflict
the cessation should set the foundation
for a lasting peace settlement that
respects the sovereignty territorial
integrity and political independence of
ukraine
it should also lead to the design
of a european security order that offers
lasting security and not a generation of
new wars in europe or elsewhere
finally
i reaffirmed kenya's respect for the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders i thank you
i thank the representative of kenya for
their statement and give the floor to
representative of ghana
thank you mr president at the outset
let me thank usg rosemary dicarlo for
her briefing
to the council on the prevailing
situation in ukraine and the rising
humanitarian suffering
occasioned by the war
i also acknowledge the virtual
participation of the president of
ukraine his excellency mr volidime
zelinski
my delegation reaffirms its unwavering
support for the sovereignty political
independence
and territorial integrity of ukraine
ghana is gravely concerned by the
reports of the intensification
of military bombardments in several
regions across ukraine over the past
couple of days and for which the
ordinary people especially women and
children
are having to pay the highest price
we remain concerned that residential
areas continue to be the target of
missile launches and
bombardments and regret that such places
have increasingly become the arena for
combat
in this context we call for an
independent impartial and transparent
investigations
into the crimean chuk mall attack which
occurred yesterday and resulted in
several casualties
over the last four months the war has
continued unabated under conditions
that have precipitated considerable
human suffering
and despair while the president's
situation casts a grim outlook for peace
as perverse of global peace and security
we cannot and must not
lose hope of finding peace in the
interest of the conflicting parties and
the wider international community
with each passing day the urgency to
find a peaceful
and durable solution to the conflict
grows
the snowballing effect of the collateral
economic impact on the rest of the
international community
especially developing countries which
already are burdened by the impact of
the covet-19 pandemic
and other pressing global challenges
could soon go beyond the rich of easy
resolution
it is therefore our plea that
ongoing diplomatic efforts should be
given an opportunity for the course of
peace
and the abatement of this needless war
on the basis of a commitment to genuine
and unconditional dialogue we welcome
the positive results that follow the
secretary-general's visit to kiev
and moscow during the month of april
which demonstrate for us
the utility of the united nations in
such delicate circumstances
we encourage the parties to accept the
good offices of the secretary-general in
repairing the broken trust
occasioned by the war against ukraine in
order to move forward
stored negotiations
we call for an immediate cessation of
military engagement in areas populated
by civilians
and urged the urgent creation of
demilitarized humanitarian corridors in
all besieged areas in compliance with
the precepts
of international law and international
humanitarian law
we note the obligation of the
conflicting parties to proactively
protect civilians
and civilian infrastructure from harm
similarly aid and humanitarian workers
must be afforded equal treatment of
protection
in concluding we urge maximum restraint
and encourage rhetoric that is
facilitative of a peaceful process
finally we reiterate our call to the
members of this council
to harness all efforts in bringing an
end to this war
and restoring peace and stability to
ukraine i thank you
i thank the representative of ghana for
their statement and i give the floor to
representative of mexico
unfortunately once again
areas in various regions of ukraine
including
yet but there are at least 18 deaths and
dozens
which is deplorable
an attack of this kind runs counter to
international
humanitarian and international
humanitarians
of residential areas in numerous places
which have destroyed critical
communications
infrastructure and services
these have seriously affected the
provision of essential health services
and
access to various citizens of the region
unhindered access
to
and to reduce damage to a minimum
failing to respect this principle
a flagrant violation of international
humanitarian laws
the same place
is particularly worrisome
continued conflict increasingly likely
excelencias
evacuation of the population
and to find mechanisms to mobilize
your grain fertilizer and other
commodities
in ukraine
bringing an end to the war is a matter
of urgency thank you president i thank
the representative of mexico for their
statement and i give the floor to the
representative of the russian federation
thank you mr president
taken by the albanian presidency
regarding the
participation of president zilensky in
today's meeting
no consultations were held with all the
members of the council on this matter
delegations were essentially presented
with the fed accompli at the last
possible moment
this
was already provided with an opportunity
to address the council once as a matter
of exception and as
the then british presidency assured
without creating a presidency
we do not see any basis to keep
propagating such exceptions
we have all together repeatedly
reaffirmed the understanding
the representatives of states who wish
to speak in the council must be
physically present in the chamber
security council should not
be turned into
in order to get more weapons from
participants of the nato center
this undermines the authority of the
council as a body responsible for
collective
the ukrainian party at the instigation
of our western colleagues is attempting
to undermine
authority and turn the members of the
council into an audience for acting
performances
just a week ago
mr foreign affairs of the central
african republic was refused the
opportunity to speak to the council
the council should not
demonstrate double standards
in order to serve the ukrainian party
and its western backers
discriminating against african states
while they do so exclusively
aimed at ending the
true situation on the front line was not
the main concern of ukrainian
authorities
or even a collected body of works
[Music]
ukrainian garrison of the island was
alive and well and had safely
surrendered to the russian army
the legend was not rewritten and ukraine
still proudly issues stamps with this
patriotic story
how about the famous pilot
it became to take a more relaxed
approach
and even to publish its own resolution
destroyed by ukrainian shelling for
buildings
ukrainians
taking advantage of the voluntary
withdrawal of russian troops from the
key of international regions
which was monstrous in its scale and
equally monstrous
mandatory
supplies from sponsors
end of quote
the armed forces of ukraine and this
crime is so obvious
in the best tradition
rapist and marauder began to be
implanted
exactly the same way
the nazis did during the final stage of
the second year
according to ukrainian progress
and their tales began to loot
never had such miraculous appliances
where soldiers now allegedly electric
kettles but forget to take the basis for
them because they don't know how to use
them
in the west
fell apart
all right
and
foreign
[Music]
ukrainian and western countries
evidence from the liberated and fiercely
shocked
as well
artillery previously
moreover there were also the military
failures caused by the inept actions
of the ukrainian command
barely armed
soldiers newberry
and not allowing them to surrender and
save their lives
from doing this or retreating
detachments of nationalists who shoot
their own in the back
familiar to ukrainian officials
attributing everything
was necessary but the problem was that
the russian army had not retreated from
anywhere
and planting courses or shooting
civilians only made sense only on
territories that had been brought back
under kiev's control
that is when apparently the idea came
in reality there was no strength
european countries
in the area of the criminals
armed forces allowed to prevent this
artillery supplied by the west give the
armed forces of ukraine the opportunity
remote rear areas
any military purpose whatsoever but only
unity
by the armed forces
yes
of such strikes against civilians and
civilians
not heard once today from our western
colleagues
extermination of the people of donetsk
and new hampshire for eight years as it
was going on
returning
shopping center was
located some distance
and it was not hit this can be seen
if a missile hit the shopping center
nothing would have been left
ammunition for western weapons that was
stored in the warehouse created a fire
which then spread to the shopping center
our dear western colleagues
have gone into
of ukrainian agate prop
propaganda propaganda
not only the fakes and the stages
allegedly preventing the exports of
ukrainian grain
support in the form of money
you must understand the shipments of the
ladder
from the very beginning
become legitimate
that you allegedly
against
for example
defense systems that shot down their own
anti-aircraft missiles over the building
your unwillingness
is
rather than with slogans and phantom
pains when actually especially
we began the special military operation
in order
to stop the shelling
and so that
is
will
thank you for your attention
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for their statement i
give the floor to representative of
india
thank you mr president let me begin by
thanking
under secretary general rosemary dicarlo
for briefing on the situation in ukraine
we acknowledged the participation and
remarks of president of ukraine in
today's briefing
india remains deeply concerned over the
situation in ukraine
the conflict has resulted in loss of
lives and countless miseries for its
peoples particularly for women children
and elderly with millions becoming
homeless
and forced to take shelter in
neighboring countries
from the beginning of the conflict in
ukraine india has been consistently
calling for complete cessation of
hostilities and advocated the path of
peace dialogue and diplomacy
we support all efforts to alleviate the
suffering of the people of ukraine
especially talks between ukraine and the
russian federation
india has also said has been sending
humanitarian supplies to ukraine and its
neighbors which include medicines and
other essential relief material
reports of deaths of civilians in the
ongoing russia ukraine conflict are
deeply disturbing
and in this regard we express our grave
concern
in recent years critical civilian
infrastructure in urban areas have
become easy targets in situations of
harm conflict
the issue of the protection of civilian
objects in armed conflict should be
considered within the framework of
applicable international law
earlier india had an
condemned the killings of civilians in
bhusha and supported the call for an
independent investigation
mr president
the impact of the ukraine conflict is
not just limited to europe
the conflict is exacerbating concerns
over food fertilizer fuel security
particularly in the developing countries
it is necessary for all of us to
adequately appreciate the importance of
equity affordability and accessibility
when it comes to food grains
open markets must not become an argument
to perpetuate inequity and promote
discrimination
india is committed to work
constructively in mitigating the adverse
impact of the conflict on food security
we have welcomed the recommendation of
the global crisis response group task
team to exempt purchases of food by wfp
for humanitarian assistance from food
export restrictions
india has been providing financial
assistance as well as supplying food
grains to countries which are impacted
by the ukraine conflict
india has exported 1.8 million tons of
wheat to countries in need including to
afghanistan myanmar sudan and yemen in
the last two months
we are also helping our neighbor sri
lanka to ensure their food security
we are trying to increase the production
of fertilizers in india
there is also a need to focus on the
availability of fertilizers and keep the
supply chains of fertilizers smooth at a
global scale
similarly effort should be made to
ensure stability in the global supply of
fuel communicate with the demand
we reiterate that the importance of uh
human guiding principles of humanitarian
assistance
humanitarian action must always be
guided by the principles of humanitarian
assistance that is humanity neutrality
impartiality and independence these
measures
should never be politicized
let me conclude mr president by
reaffirming that the contemporary global
order has been built on the un charter
international law and respect for
sovereignty and the territorial
integrity of states i thank you
i thank representative of india for
their statement thank you this lord
representative of china
is a great concern to the international
community in china
always
made its independent assessments based
on historical contexts and merits of
ukrainian issues
to respect sovereignty and territorial
integrity of all countries
to adhere to the purposes and principles
of the u.n charter
for some time now china has joined all
peace loving countries
calling for a ceasefire we have been
keenly committed to promoting peace
talks
and made our remaining efforts for
de-escalating the situation early
restoration
and
mitigating humanitarian situations
and stabilizing the global economic
order
it is requestable
humanitarian situation remains directed
in casualties
and
people
are suffering
good for me and the way multifaceted
spiritual effects
are
exacerbating global challenges
is the only viable way to restore and
consolidate peace
and ending hostilities
is a keen aspiration of the
international community
alternate supports direct negotiations
between russia and
ukraine
welcome
secretary general's good officers
grain export among others
mr president
is for autist rifle and to defend
yourself
all members of the international
community should responsibility
environment and conditions for peace
talks by the parties
facts have fully borne out that sending
weapons cannot bring about peace
no can sanctions and pressurization
solve the security
less secure
delaying and obstructing diplomatic
negotiations for geopolitical processes
or even adding fuel to the fire to
intensify confrontation with only
magnified conflict
this ukrainian crisis
once again sound alarm for the world
security is indivisible
with a blind faith in the position of
strength and expansion of military
alliances
and a pursuit of once unsecured at the
expense of other country security will
inevitably lead to security
nato's
five eastwood expansions
have not only failed to make europe
secure
but also so the seas of conflict it is a
lesson
that is worse than good reflecting
the cold war ended a long time ago it is
necessary for nato to reconsider its own
positioning and its
responsibilities completely abandoned
the code or mentality that is based on
confrontation
balanced effective
and sustainable
paying security framework in line with
the principle of indivisible security
like all peace loving countries and
people in the world
pays close attention to nato strategic
adjusting
[Music]
involvement in asia-pacific
and prosperity and a wish
to focus on mutually beneficial
cooperation in pursuit of common
development and revitalization
against the tide of history
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of china for
their statement now give this lord to
representative of the united arab
emirates
mr president at the outset i would like
to thank uh ms rosemary de carlo for her
detailed briefing we acknowledge
president zielinski's address to the
council and his first-hand account of
the latest developments in ukraine
we meet today following concerning
reports of intensified missile strikes
across ukraine and urban areas including
kiev and kharkiv in particular the
images in kremenchuk of a shopping mall
something familiar to all of us in our
everyday life engulfed in flames are
horrifying
this incident has added to the war's
immensely high human toll and should be
properly investigated
incidents like these are a clear
demonstration of why civilian objects
are protected under international law
the uae reiterates its unequivocal
condemnation of attacks on civilians and
civilian objects and infrastructure
with the conflict now entering its fifth
month women and children and the elderly
are disproportionately impacted more
than half of ukraine's children are now
displaced from home and women children
and the elderly are suffering from
ongoing violence and trauma and seeking
refuge in neighboring countries
it is well past time that we find
parameters for ceasefire negotiations as
a starting point to end this war
if the conflict continues unabated we
can expect the tsunami of global
ramifications to worsen
people around the world are already
suffering both directly and from the
conflict's wider repercussions including
distorted global trade the effects of
sanctions and increased food prices
threatening a global recession the most
vulnerable as always are the worst
affected
in this context i would like to make the
following points
first the application of international
humanitarian law is fundamental to
preserving human life
compliance is both the moral and the
legal obligation
and we reiterate the importance of
respecting the principles of necessity
distinction and proportionality that are
paramount in conflict as well as the
importance of ensuring accountability
any military operation must be limited
to exclusively military objectives and
all precautionary measures must be taken
to avoid the direct or indirect
targeting of civilians
the fact that the war in ukraine has so
greatly affected heavily urbanized areas
with high density civilian populations
only underlines the imperative of
applying the principles outlined in the
council's framework on the protection of
civilians and civilian objects
second the international community
should intensify efforts to de-escalate
and engage proactively to end this
conflict almost two months have passed
since this council adopted a
presidential statement expressing deep
concern regarding the maintenance of
international peace and security in
ukraine
the war in ukraine however has continued
to escalate the un charter outlines many
of the tools that can be deployed to
reach a peaceful settlement but knowing
that the tools exist or that they are at
the disposal of the parties is not
enough the talk needs to be walked and
now is the time to have an actual
dialogue on the humanitarian challenges
and to prioritize an immediate cessation
of hostilities laying out the contours
of a sustainable solution that ends this
conflict and ends it on a foundation
upon which peace can be built
we encourage the parties to seize this
opportunity and we urge the secretary
general and others in trying to bring
together the parties for good faith
negotiations to this end
third helping ease global food
insecurity must be a priority this
cannot wait we must avoid a food
catastrophe we are already facing what
david beasley so vividly described as
having to take food from the hungry to
feed the starving
specifically there needs to be a
solution to export the grain and
fertilizer that are so critical to food
systems around the world we are
encouraged by ongoing efforts aimed at
allowing ships safe passage to and from
key seaports including odessa the
security council must do everything
within its power to support these
negotiations and we look forward to the
council addressing this in more detail
finally mr president the devastation in
ukraine from this war is undeniable we
risk a lost generation of children
denied education and opportunity we need
to redouble our efforts to achieve peace
and end this human suffering this
council must exhaust all avenues and
spare no efforts to this objective thank
you mr president
i thank the representative of the uae
for their statement and i give the floor
to the representative of gabon
merci president thank you mr president
i thank under secretary general mr
robert carlos for her briefing
participation welcome to the virtual
participation of president zielenski in
this meeting
mr
as the political and diplomatic horizon
appears to be receding and shrinking
to nothing
humanitarian crisis resulting from the
war we must absolutely be stemmed too
many civilians have paid their lives and
millions of the many women and children
have been forced to flee combat areas to
seek refuge in other cities
the outpouring of international
solidarity to host ukrainian refugees
and despite the commitment of the united
specialized agencies
the humanitarian situation in ukraine is
worsening with the bombardment
the destruction of production
distribution facilities and the
disruption of value chains or ukraine
outside ukraine
the consequences of the war are
distributing food and security in
countries already
urgently needed food aid don't member
at the same time many countries are
facing unprecedented economic inflation
so we're just straining their economies
this gloomy picture yeah
many farmers
refrain from any use of weapons of mass
destruction and do everything possible
to facilitate
unimpeded and secure access
to humanitarian aid
and civilian infrastructure must not be
targeted we condemn the artillery fire
targeting a shopping center
in central ukraine yesterday
tendency to trivialize the threat of the
use of weapons of mass destruction as a
matter of concern
to the treaty on the non-proliferation
of the nuclear weapons
my country continues to believe that the
best way to end the humanitarian case
outbreak of violence
to end the conflict
diplomatic and political challenge
channels in order to find a negotiated
and
consensual solution to the conflict
peace and security
must remain the ultimate objective
towards which the initiatives of all the
parties and of the international
community converge
for the cessation of hostilities
with
you to returning to peaceful coexistence
thank you
i thank the representative of gabon for
her statement
representative of norway
thank you president
i thank you usg de carlo for shedding
further light on the situation in
ukraine
and the continued attacks against
civilians by russian forces
i welcome also the strong testimony of
president zielenski on behalf of the
people of ukraine
first
norway reiterates that russia's war
is
in and of itself a violation of
international law
the principles of the u.n charter are
clear on the illegality of the
acquisition of territory by force
we reiterate our call for russia to stop
its illegal attack on ukraine
immediately
second
norway strongly condemns all violations
of international humanitarian law and
international human rights law
we condemn in the strongest term the
reported killings of ukrainian civilians
and we call on russia to immediately end
this indiscriminate and deliberate
attacks against civilians and civilian
infrastructure in ukraine
the targeting of residential areas such
as the devastating missile attack
against a shopping center in kramerchuk
yesterday
is unacceptable
the urban warfare and intensified
russian missile attacks against kiev
kharkiv and other cities is causing
immense civilian suffering
we reiterate our demand and the demand
of international law
that the civilian population must be
protected and that all necessary
measures be taken to avoid civilian
casualties
international humanitarian law must be
fully respected and implemented
we condemn belarus for facilitating
russia's attack on
ukraine third
violation of international law cannot go
unchallenged
all violation needs to be investigated
and perpetrators of any crimes must be
brought to justice
we support the investigation by the icc
the office of the prosecutor general of
ukraine and other international
investigations
president as the war in ukraine
continues it is inflicting a terrible
cumulative harm on the civilian
population
undermining prospects for peace and
security
the protection of civilians and human
rights is a prerequisite for sustainable
peace after conflict
in ukraine
the best way to protect civilians is
clear
it is for russia to end this war
thank you
i thank the representative of norway for
their statement
the representative of the united kingdom
has asked for the floor to make a
further statement and i give them the
power
thank you president
i don't want to take too much more time
but i wanted to say that the russian
representative
can try to claim that nothing is true
and make outrageous claims of ukrainian
provocations
cover-ups
are as old as crime itself
but the undeniable fact
is that russian forces are in ukraine
and there are no ukrainian forces in
russia
there is one aggressor here
the evidence will catch up with them
and there will be accountability for
these crimes
thank you
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom
for their statement the representative
of the russian federation has asked for
the floor to make a further statement
and give them the floor
thank you mr president i will also be
brief it won't take too much of your
time i just wanted to know that
such statements
sound very convincing coming from a
representative of a country that brought
the world such
next time you try to teach us lessons
i thank the representative of the
russian federation
for this further statement and i give
the floor not representative of estonia
mr president i speak on behalf of the
baltic countries latvia lithuania and my
own country estonia
i thank the albanian presidency for
organizing this briefing and under
secretary general rose marity carlo for
the updates on russia's full-scale
barbaric military
aggression
against an independent and sovereign
country that wishes nothing more than
living in peace and freedom to choose
their own destiny free from foreign
interference in its internal affairs
we warmly welcome president zelinski's
participation in this meeting and
commend him and the ukrainian people for
their hairy courage and resistance for
the freedom of their country
and for the freedom of us all
crime against aggression is a prime
crime against the international law
putin's regime has unleashed a colonial
neo-imperialist expansionist war against
ukraine amplified by the obscene
dehumanizing disinformation campaign
against ukraine and the identity
language history and the right to exist
the ukrainian people
the security council most urgently
perform its duties to stop this
unfolding catastrophe
as we have seen over the course of four
months
124 days now
unable to defeat the defendants of
ukraine in the battlefield
russia's military seeks to achieve its
aims
by terrorizing civilians
we have already seen this too many times
maternity hospitals schools
kindergartens residential buildings and
now also shopping centers are targeted
indiscriminately and without any remorse
russia's terror knows no bounds the
shelling of a coded shopping center in
kermanczuk as well as numerous other
intense intensified attacks on ukrainian
cities
slovenians kharkiv kiev in recent days
had no military justification whatsoever
no justification other than to kill
injure and cause extensive human
suffering and thereby hope that the
spirit of ukrainian people will be
broken the calls for peace at all costs
will grow and that the demands of their
geyser will subsequently be met
this is the diplomacy russian way by
using terror and blackmail
the russian actions represent flagrant
violations of international law
including the united nations charter
russia has repeatedly ignored the calls
by the u.n general assembly as well as
the other
as well as the order of the
international court of justice to
immediately suspend the military
operations in its territory of ukraine
and withdraw its armed forces from
ukraine
the borders of a country are not to be
changed by force
this demand is the heart and soul of the
yuan charter
the systemic violations of humanitarian
law and human rights
deliberate attacks on civilian objects
and civilians executions sexual and
gender-based violence arbitrary arrests
abductions enforced disappearances and
forced deportations of civilians
including unaccompanied children to
russia as well as their illegal adoption
committed against ukrainian people among
to war crimes and crimes against
humanity and possibly even genocide
the international community should not
spare any effort to ensure that those
responsible for these atrocious crimes
are held to account
we need collectively to give our
strongest support to the ongoing work by
the prosecutor of the international
criminal court the independent
international commission of inquiry
mandated by the united nations human
rights council
and the work of the expert mission under
the moscow mechanism of the organization
for security and cooperation in europe
as well as the national investigation by
the office of prosecutor general of
ukraine
justice will be brought to the victims
and their families
mr president we are concerned that yet
again has russia resorted to dangerous
and irresponsible nuclear
rhetoric by announcing its intention to
transfer nuclear
capable missiles to belarus
and upgrading belarus warplanes to make
them capable of carrying nuclear weapons
we urge russian belarus to act in line
with their international commitments and
sees destabilizing nuclear
sovereigntylink
any use of weapons of mass destruction
is unacceptable and leads to severe
consequences we here herewith strongly
condemn the involvement of belarus as
much as complicit in this aggression
against ukraine
we also strongly condemn russia's
weaponizing food to increase food
shortage and global hunger and thus
nebula destabilize international
security
recent reports have shown that russian
forces have been systemic
systematically stealing crane and other
products from local farmers in occupied
areas of ukraine as a result of russia's
military activity more than 20 million
tons of grain is currently blocked in
ukraine we fully support the efforts of
the united nations to find an urgently
needed solution for the expert of
ukraine's crane and urge russia to
ensure free passage of shipping from
ukrainian ports
mr president
let me reiterate that it is the
obligation of each member of the
international community to stand up
against those who violate the principles
and rules of international law
including the yuan charter
otherwise we risk losing the
international rules-based order be built
and committed to since the end of the
world war ii
fundamental principles of respecting
sovereignty territorial integrity and
refraining from the use of force are to
be respected by every country and are
not for debate
we resolutely condemn russia's war a
vocation against ukraine we urge once
again russia to immediately stop its
indiscriminate attacks against civilians
and civilian infrastructure
and to immediately and unconditionally
withdraw all its troops and military
equipment from the entire territory of
ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders
estonia latvia and lithuania stand with
ukraine and the ukrainian people
thank you
i thank the representative of estonia
for their statement and i give the floor
to representative of poland
mr president
thank you for convening this important
meeting
i also take this opportunity to thank
usg de carlo for her briefing
as well as his excellency president
zelinski for his powerful statement
mr president
irrespectively of what we have heard
again from the russian representative
today
russia is waging a total war against
ukraine
a total war
which from its very beginning 124 days
ago has been in total lack of respect
for the international humanitarian law
and human rights law
we have a duty to repeat it over and
over again
even though
the aggressors themselves keep reminding
us
about the true character of their
actions with every atrocity they commit
yesterday's deadly rocket attack
launched by russian forces on a bustling
shopping center in kremenchuk was just
the latest in the long list of those
somber reminders
as the hard-ranging images are still
before our eyes
we need to be loud and clear
in only the past four days
russia has fired over 130 missiles on
ukrainian cities of kiev
kharkiv mikolai and odessa
to name just a few
by deciding to hit objects of no
military significance
moscow wants to cause large human losses
terrorize the civilian population
and disrupt the functioning of
infrastructure catering to everyday
needs of ordinary ukrainians
according to cautious estimates provided
by the ohchr
only between june 23rd and june 26
more than 120 civilian casualties
weren't confirmed
the shelling of the amster mall in
kremenchuk alone killed at least 20
people and injured 60 more
moscow is not only disregarding
humanitarian issues and ignoring
international criticism
it wants to show that it will strive to
break the resistance of the ukrainian
authorities
by all means and coasts
mr president
with respect to the imported topic we
are discussing russia continues
to disrespect this council and the u.n
charter
it is particularly cynical that russia a
permanent member of the security council
which has been entrusted with the
responsibility for maintenance of
international peace and security
is not only failing to fulfill its basic
responsibilities but acts as an
aggressor in blatant disregard for
disorganization
and the foundational rules the
international peace and security
mechanisms have been built on
it is our duty to work together to
collect and preserve the evidence of all
violations of human rights and
international humanitarian law that have
taken place in ukraine
poland's position in this regard is
clear
all those responsible directly and
indirectly for committing war crimes in
ukraine should be brought to justice
apart from seeking justice
ukraine has a full right to defend
itself and expect the international
community to provide necessary
assistance in this regard
humanitarian military and financial aid
allows ukrainians to protect their
citizens secure their basic needs and
ensure post-war recovery for 124 days
now
ukrainians have been bravely putting
resistance to their aggressors forces
which continue to strive for a
territorial grab
which might actually never satisfy their
appetite for more
the responsibility for the russian
actions lies also with belarus which
since the 24th of february has been
actively facilitating moscow's military
action by making its airspace territory
and infrastructure available to russian
troops
if not for minsk support
russia's aggression would have been
limited
belarusian leadership should be
considered complicit of crimes committed
by russia in ukraine
mr president
once more we urge the russian federation
to stop the war
and to fully withdraw all its forces
from the territory of ukraine
this is the only way to prevent further
deaths of civilians we also urge russia
to fully respect the sovereignty
independence and territorial integrity
of ukraine as well as international
humanitarian law and human rights law
in particular
i think
i thank the representative of poland for
their statement
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers
this meeting is adjourned
uh
you